cela fait 20 ans qu'elle a choisi cette
voie katia hamon ou plutôt capitaine
katia hamon est infirmière sapeur
pompier professionnel au sein de la
caserne de saint germain en laye pour
elle ce métier était une évidence il ya
toujours que ce choix alors l'expliquer
c'est toujours assez compliqué il ya
toujours eu que ce choix je pense qu'on
devient infirmière canton à genoux donne
toujours cette qualité aux infirmiers
aux soignants aux soignants cette
qualité c'est l'empathie
je pense que tout soit nyon et
un de manière générale on a vraiment
cette semaine - alors pas de sauver 1
ce côté sauveteurs il n'est pas du tout
pas du tout adapté au jeu de je pense
mais c'est cette empathie
c'est cette envie d'être là pour les
gens qui en ont besoin
diplôme d'infirmière en poche katia
débute alors sa carrière dans le milieu
hospitalier
j'ai débuté en services d'urgence et de
ce mur donc c'est une pour moi une
expérience qu'il était indispensable
pour être aujourd'hui dans la fonction
opérationnelle que j'occupe ensuite j'ai
commencé en tant que volontaire à
l'infirmière volontaire je côtoyais de
manière très régulière des sapeurs
pompiers en intervention
un jour un poste se libère une
opportunité pour katia elle rejoint
alors les rangs des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels un nouveau défi cela fait
presque dix ans 12 7
en fait nous faisons les visites
médicales de tous les sapeurs pompiers
du département à une fréquence qui les
réglementent et 1
nous agissons dans les médicale urgente
au quotidien et également dans la partie
soutien sanitaire opérationnel
c'est-à-dire dans des interventions à
grande dimension ou à dimension
spécifique auprès de nos sapeurs
pompiers la deuxième mission
opérationnelle aujourd'hui c'est
l'officier santé au codis depuis le
début février nous avons une salle
unique d'appel donc c'est la partie 18
on ne peut pas tout savoir
on ne peut pas tout à prendre et tout
tout tout connaître
en une seule formation et notre
quotidien en fait c'est une c'est une
adaptation continuelle et j'apprends
toujours dans mon métier tous les jours
avec la crise sanitaire le quotidien de
katia a évidemment changé
une mission l'a particulièrement marqué
elle a collaboré avec l' agence
régionale de santé pour effectuer les
tests pcr dans les ehpad
durant le premier confinement le tout
début la mission je n'ai pas trop
dimensionné ça a pris énormément
d'ampleur parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait des personnes âgées qui
étaient enfermés dans leur chambre
alors c'est plus ou moins grand depuis
plusieurs mois et qui ne voyaient pas
leurs familles et pam les soignants
venait très très peu puisque devait pas
du tout les exposer pocovi on avait des
personnes qu'on venait voir qu'ils
étaient mal an certaines fois c'était
d'une émotion mais terrible qu'elle un
monsieur on leur disait on va vous faire
un test et puis ben après c'est en
fonction des résultats les portes vont
s'ouvrir vers l'extérieur
donc ça a été une mission un prenante
que pas par le temps mais vraiment par
l'émotion et par l'humain qu'on pouvait
rencontrer le capitaine a aussi
participé à la formation des chiens à
détecter le coc vide
elle s'est occupée de récupérer les
prélèvements de sueur dans les centres
hospitaliers du département d adaptation
mais surtout de la passion c'est ce qui
anime le capitaine katia hamon